life is not something to rush through
and get over with you know i think a lot
of people's idea of what life is is that
you're trying to arrange your death bed
scene
you know it should take place in a large
palatial home preferably paid for
and you lie there in a vast bed glowing
relatives surrounding you millions of
dollars about to flow to them from your
quiet and painless death they're
surrounded by the works of art and the
retainers and well this is squirrely
thinking it's this kind of thinking
i mean even if you achieve it you know
you'll love all those people and as you
move your gaze from face to face you'll
see avaricious weasels waiting to plant
you
so why not just
get on with the business of life and
and live it
i mean the way i think about this is
i've always been interested in the
peculiar and the bizarre and i'm
interested in physical beauty of a
certain sort so very early on i was like
a rock hunter
and the concept for me at that level was
you find these rocks which don't look
like much and you break them open
and then inside there is mineral
iridescence
or 100 million year old clam shells
or stuff like this that nature is full
of secrets and
somehow and i don't know why this is
as most people live their lives
they forget this
and they become more and more mundane
they become less and less themselves and
more and more a citizen
a mother a lover a son a daughter roles
displaced being
and for some reason this didn't really
happen to me
and i just kept pushing
you know butterflies
erotica
philosophy
heresy
magic
and then drugs
and lo and behold
this is the path out of the mundane
world
the world is not what they say it is
everything they say is wrong
you know the world is
labyrinthine beyond possibility of
imagining inhabited on many levels by
alien intelligence infinite in extent
staggering in its beauty terrifying in
its weirdness
endlessly satisfying and peculiar and
this is all this is the secret i mean we
used to call it the secret
but all civilization
i don't care whether you're living in
second temple jerusalem or gothic france
or modern new york culture
is a plot
to hide this fact from you to keep you
from finding out this fact
that there are doorways out of ordinary
reality into worlds
impossible to describe and too strange
to suppose
imagine too strange to suppose meaning
that no matter how bizarre your
presuppositions
they fall short of the real nature of
reality
[Music]
you